my first day was with Millie it was on  paper a really short sin yeah it was  just I'm waiting for an error and she  comes in and then she has a little cry  and um they cut the ceiling but in the  at the by the end of the day we were but  remember we were both like on the floor  sobbing together yeah the scene had like  progressed into something it was a great  day release over my first day nerves but  I think from that I was like okay that  was that was my worst nightmare for like  my second day that was my second day  yeah I was like why can't I just like  walk around I want to walk around class  when he was just like walking walking  I'll walk in there we'll be ready